[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute ein
schnelles no baic rezept ich habe mir
gedacht jetzt wo es so warm ist und ich
unter meinem was war das letzte was
vorletzte oder den letzter tag video auf
dem er geschrieben im möchte ich auch
für den sommer gerne nowak rezepte
schnelle rezepte die praktisch sind und
die gut vorbereiten können
so und jetzt machen wir ein windbeutel
nowak rezept mit erdbeeren etwa ihr
wisst ich liebe es muss man komplett
auskosten ich hab aber heute allerdings
muss ich ehrlich sagen tiefgekühlt
bender und frischem später für die deko
weil ich nicht mehr so viele frische
dahab so nicht starten wie direct ich
habe hier joghurt nimmt gerne
zehnprozentigen oder 35 prozentigen ich
hab jetzt hier den 35 prozentigen noch
da gehabt aber den komplett fettarmen
also 15 und 0,1 würde ich jetzt hier
nicht empfehlen sondern gebe ich jetzt
mit dazu dann haben wir noch mascarpone
ich habe heute auf seine verzichtet
nämlich nochmals capone dazu die könnt
ihr auch durch frischkäse ersetzen
und da kommt dann puderzucker mit rein
und der zitronen also der schein abrieb
einer zitrone
du bist du still sag mal war es okay ihr
wisst ich hab ja gut rein gegeben und
mascarpone haben so wie die cdu dann
machen wir weiter
ja gibt's wieder okay ganz sicher so
weitergeht genau puderzucker für die
süße habe ich euch ja gerade schon
gesagt und ich bin auch keine
küchenmaschine berühren jetzt alles mit
dem schneebesen jetzt habe ich hier eine
bio zitrone wichtig ist eben dass sie
nicht gespritzt ist und bio ist damit
noch die schale verwenden können weil
die schmeckt so aromatisch dafür dem ich
jetzt meine citrus reiber also meine
fein reiben die geht auch für käse
verlege ich euch in der infobox und ich
werde auch gleich noch ein bisschen
zitronensaft reingehen aber nur so
ungefähr 1 teelöffel
um den geschmack zu verfeinern gebe ich
jetzt auch vanille extrakt dazu ich bin
der meinung zitrone und vanille ist
einfach das perfekte team genauso wie du
und ich haben sie das ist aber liebt es
jetzt den müll raus mitmachen kaffee
[Musik]
so schon fertig also die creme ist ein
sehr weich ich mache jetzt auch extra
keinen sahne fest oder gelatine oder
magazine rein und ich probier's mal ob
es mir genug süßes ist und das kann ich
das immer noch verändern
perfekt nächsten esslöffel extra wegen
dir so und jetzt nehme ich mir die
erdbeeren die habe ich auftauen lassen
ihr könnt auch frische nehmen und die
pure ich jetzt ganz einfach
[Musik]
ich habe noch wasser und zucker mit zu
erdmasse gegeben einfach für die
konsistenz und für die süße und jetzt
können wir das ganze schichten ich habe
dazu noch windbeutel aus dem
tiefkühlfach genommen das sind diese
etwa windbeutel könnt sie natürlich auch
selber machen
aber ganz ehrlich wer hat lust drauf bei
dem wetter ich zugegebenermaßen nicht
aber ich verlinke euch auch mein
windbeutel video hier unten in die
infobox und ich guck mal wie ich das
schicht ich glaube ich liebe sagt erstes
dieses erdbeerpüree wieder auch das
schick aussieht sondern gebe ich da ein
oder zwei weiß ich gar nicht einfach mal
erst mal reicht es kommt auch oft die
größe an so und dann von der leckeren
creme und dann würde ich nochmal mit dem
erdbeerpüree abschließen und dann gebe
ich frische erdbeeren und noch frische
minze mit drauf so klicks würde das
reichen in die mitte
[Musik]
so ich mache jetzt doch strudel hier
oben einfach mit einem zahnstocher rein
das finde ich auch
sodann hamas auch schon wie schnell ging
das bitter also wenn ihr jetzt sagte er
dort mit solange dann weiß ich auch
nicht weiter dass mich jetzt echt mega
mega schnell ja so hat auf jeden fall
auf jeden fall so ein besuch einfach um
sich selbst zu verwöhnen einfach wenn
ihr auf dem balkon stellen möchte also
das passt perfekt und es ist sehr
erfrischend und euch wünsche ich jetzt
ganz viel freude beim nachmachen ihr
könnt die ganz genauen mengenangaben sie
unten in der video beschreibung lesen
dann könnt ihr neben dem titel den pfeil
anklicken und dann kommt ja direkt drauf
ich sage das jetzt gerne mal extra dazu
weisen ganz viele neue hierarchie
community die wissen das vielleicht noch
nicht und wenn ihr weitere
rezeptvorschläge habt immer immer her
damit
und dann würde ich mal sagen was zu
meinem nächsten videos eure kiki